hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ztf heute
live über die Zukunft der Ukraine
sprechen über das VI für und wieder von
Waffenlieferungen wie dieser Krieg enden
kann womöglich mit friedensverhandlung
mit Verhandlung mit Russland all das ist
leicht wenn man im sicheren Westen im
warmen ist wo keine Raketen fliegen wenn
man in der Ukraine ist was ich selbst
auch noch bis vor anderthalb Wochen war
wenn nachts russische Drohnen auf
ukrainische Städte im ganzen Land ziähen
wenn Wohnhäuser getroffen werden wenn
fast täglich Menschen verletzt oder
getötet werden dann ist das schwer
Regierungs und Staatschefs der
unterstützerländer im Westen wie
Deutschland und die USA die beteuern
öffentlich dass noch nicht die Zeit für
Verhandlungen ist und dass allein die
Ukraine über Verhandlungen entscheide es
gibt aber stimmen die fordern dass es
ein Ausstiegsszenario nach dem Krieg
geben muss der militärisch nicht zu winn
sei so heißt es dann häufig so eine
Stimme haben wir uns heute eingeladen
der US-amerikanische Politikberater
Samuel ch ist bei uns er wird uns hier
in der Sendung all das was er dazu denkt
und erläutert erklären ihr könnt auch
Fragen dazu stellen er sagt es ist sehr
wohl möglich dass wir gleichzeitig
kämpfen und Verhandlungen führen stellt
also Fragen direkt im Stream oder per
Mail ich möchte ihn ganz kurz vorstellen
in ein paar Sätzen und wir schauen auch
gleich noch in einen Überblick der
aktuellen Situation Samel ch ist
politiks ler hat Russisch und
osteuropastudien in Oxford studiert er
spricht auch Ukrainisch er ist führender
Politikwissenschaftler bei der a
corporation die wird finanziert unter
anderem vom US
Verteidigungsministerium und zuvor war
er unter anderem als fellow des Council
und forign relations im amerikanischen
Außenministerium tätig wir schauen jetzt
zuerst mal auf einen Überblick der
aktuellen Situation von
Christian fast Z Jahre ist es jetzt her
dass Russland seinen blutigen
Angriffskrieg gegen dieuk gestartet hat
ohne Rücksicht auf zivile Opfer täglich
neue Angriffe wie hier in der Region
hakev am Frontverlauf ändert sich nicht
viel Waffenruhe Frieden nicht in Sicht
Wladimir Putin will Frieden nur nach
russischen Bedingungen das heißt die
annektierten Gebiete in der Ukraine wird
Russland nicht zurückgeben für die
Ukraine nicht
akzeptabel Putin verkörpert diesen Krieg
wir alle wissen dass er der einzige
Grund ist warum verschiedene Kriege und
te andauern und warum alle Versuche den
Frieden wiederherzustellen gescheitert
sind er wird sich nicht
ändern was diesen Verhandlungsprozess
angeht ist das ein Versuch uns zu
zwingen die Errungenschaften aufzugeben
die wir in den letzten anderthalb Jahren
erreicht haben aber das ist unmöglich
jeder versteht dass es unmöglich ist
sowohl die herrschenden Kreise in der
Ukraine als auch die westlichen
Eliten J versteht
das doch wie könnten
Friedensverhandlungen in Gang kommen um
die russische Invasion und das Leid zu
stoppen diese große Frage bleibt weiter
unbeantwortet der amerikanische
Politologe Samuel ch veröffentlichte
letzten Sommer in der Zeitschrift
Foreign Affairs einen viel diskutierten
Artikel ch sagt weder die Ukraine noch
Russland hätten die Kraft diesen Krieg
zu gewinnen die USA und ihre Verbündeten
müssten ein Szenario für das Ende dieses
Krieges entwickeln aber wie das erklärt
Samuel ch jetzt bei ZDF heute live er
ist jetzt bei uns der
Politikwissenschaftler der RAND
Corporation hallo schön dass Sie bei uns
sind her
SH than ja vielen Dank dass ich dabei
sein darf wir haben eben gerade in dem
Beitrag noch mal die Präsidenten der
Ukraine und Russlands gehört die Zeichen
stehen nach diesen Aussagen wirklich
absolut nicht für Verhandlung was bringt
sie trotzdem dazu dass sie glauben eine
solche Forderung wäre
[Musik]
umsetzbar ich kann natürlich nicht
vorher sagen dass es kurzfristig
Gespräche geben wird im Moment ist es so
dass die Politik in der
Ukraine und in den westlichen Ländern
die Politik geht nicht die richtungs
gleiche gilt für Russland aber ich denke
dass es fair ist in einem Zusammenhang
wo keine Seite in der Position ist eine
absolute einen absoluten militärischen
Gewinn davon zu tragen da ist die
Alternative zu so einem solchen SEG ein
verhandeltes
konfliktende irgendwann wird das
passiert die Frage ist wann und unter
welchen
Bedingungen in einem Artikel des
deutschen Nachrichtenmagazins der
Spiegel v dezember ist von einem
hintergrundtreffen beim deutschen
Botschafter in Washington die Rede an
dem unter anderem auch sie und der Chef
des Bundeskanzleramts Wolfgang Schmidt
teilgenommen haben sollen wobei wir
wissen öffentlich darf man von solchen
Hintergrund treffen also gar nichts
berichten sie dürfen da gar nicht drüber
sprechen wenn es denn so gewesen sein
soll nichtsdestotrotz eine Frage an Sie
können Sie uns denn sagen ob über solch
konkrete Szenarien für ein Ende des
russischen angriffskriegs in
politikreisen in den USA wo es
öffentlich immer heißt darüber
entscheidet nur die Ukraine wird darüber
irgendwie diskutiert in diesem
politikkreisen oder
nachgedacht also ich kann natürlich
nicht das Ansprechen was in einem
privaten Gespräch diskutiert wurde das
ist natürlich jetzt nicht für die
Öffentlichkeit bestimmt ich würde
sagen es stimmt üerein mit der Position
der amerikanischen Regierung seit dem
Anfang des
Krieges irgendwann wird der Krieg
nämlich in einer Verhandlungslösung Ende
die Frage ist wann und unter welchen
Bedingungen und verschiedene Leute haben
dazu natürlich verschiedene Ansichten
was normal ist aber man kann sicherlich
sagen aus moralischer Perspektive und
praktischer Perspektive ist es so dass
die
Ukrain
natürlich diesen Prozess auch selbst
voll unterstützen müssten also praktisch
gesehen der Gedanke von Verhandlungen
oder Abkommen ohne der Unterstützung
wäre eigentlich nicht durchführbar denn
die Ukrainer müssen ja Teil der Lösung
sein anderen seit sind diejenigen die
kämpfen und sterben und Sie müssen
natürlich das dabei das Sagen haben und
das wird dann bestimmend sein das heißt
natürlich nicht dass Parteien von außen
also z.B die Partner der Ukraine dass
die nicht Ratschläge geben können oder
ihre eigene Perspektive haben könnten
wie sich dieser Konflikt
weiterentwickeln mag und was auch ihre
eigenen Interessen angeht in die weitere
Entwicklung dieses Krieges ein User bei
uns im Stream Lukas der fragt sich wie
soll man mit diesem Kriegstreiber Putin
verhandeln er will doch nur die Ukraine
erobern weil sie kein prorussischen
Präsidenten mehr hat und mehr nicht also
die Frage an Sie wie soll man mit jemand
wie Putin verhandeln der 2014
völkerrechtswidrig die Krim annektiert
hat und der dann auch die Hände
ausgestreckt hat nach dem gesamten
Gebiet der Ukraine wie soll das
gehen ich denke ihr Zuschauer hat da was
wichtiges gesagt das ursprüngliche Ziel
von Putin bei der Invasion im
Februar 2022 war ein regimwechsel und er
hat's nicht geschafft und seither haben
sich seine Ziele verändert die sind
jetzt ziemlich unklar
eigentlich und er will da jetzt wenn er
darüber spricht über seine Ziele auch
nicht so spezifisch werden aber
letztlich hat er gezeigt dass er wens
ist und bereit ist Abkommen zu letzen
wann immer es ihm gefällt aber wir
wissen ja nicht wer in Russland die
Führung hat Russland ist ja der
Aggressor der Kriegstreiber in diesem
Krieg und daher ist es so dass jede
Verhandlung über ein Ende des Krieges
auch Russland involvieren
muss wenn wir uns unsere Gegner selber
aussuchen könnten wä das natürlich toll
aber so ist es eben nicht der Westen
macht ganz klar über ung entscheidet die
Ukraine was müsste denn ihrer Meinung
nach getan werden dass die Ukraine denn
überhaupt für sowas bereit wäre wie soll
das
gehen
so ich denke die westlichen
Regierungen sollten in der Position sein
diese Frage mit der Ukraine zu
diskutieren es wäre schlecht für alle
wenn sie irgendwann an den
Verhandlungstisch gehen und nicht
vorbereitet sind Vorbereitung ist
wichtig selbst wenn die Zeit jetzt noch
nicht bereit ist um formelle
Verhandlungen zu starten und jetzt ganz
klar ist nicht die richtige Zeit aber es
ist die richtige Zeit um sich
vorzubbereiten für diesen Moment und ich
denke wir müssen mit diesen Gesprächen
jetzt anfangen selbst wenn der Prozess
vielleicht erst in 6 oder 12 Monaten
oder egal wie lange es noch dauert
beginnen kann und das wäre der erste
Schritt um
anzufangen wenn es sich zeigt dass man
kein Abkommen mit dieser russischen
Regierung bekommen kann dann haben wir
immer noch die Option
weiterzukämpfen das setzt voraus dass
man aufhört zu kämpfen um anfangen um
anzufangen zu sprechen aber die meisten
Konflikte wurden gelöst das wärend beide
Parteien gleichzeitig kämpfen und
Sprachen statt dass man erst aufhörte zu
kämpfen und dann zu sprechen ich glaub
so wir es hier auch sein die Russen und
die Ukrainer sprechen ja sie sprechen
einfach nicht über das
Ausstiegsszenario jetzt sprechen sie in
Verhandlungen über den Austausch von
Kriegsgefangenen und das sehen wir ja
schon während der ganzen Dauer des
Konfliktes hat immer wieder gegeben und
noch mal aber ganz konkret die Frage
sehen Sie keine Gefahr dass Putin nicht
auch wieder angreifen könnte wenn man
mit ihm verhandelt und es dann dazu
kommen sollte dass eben Gebiete der
Ukraine nicht zurückgewonnen GEW nicht
zurückgewonnen werden können dass Putin
dann also wieder die gesamte Ukraine
angreift oder vielleicht sogar noch mehr
noch weitere Länder angreift was soll
das Zeichen an ihn sein dass er das
nicht tut was soll das Versprechen sein
dass er das nicht
hätte also ich denke egal wo die
Konfliktlinie ist selbst wenn die
Ukraine all sein international
anerkanntes Territorium wieder erleintt
wird es immer noch der Risiko geben dass
Russland wieder angreift Russland wird
eine potenzielle Bedrohung für die
Ukraine und die anderen Nachbarn sein
egal wie der Krieg endet ich glaube
nicht dass Russland demilitarisiert wird
das wohl kaum und das ist nur mal eine
Tatsache mit der wir zurechtkommen
müssen langfristig
was für ein Signal ja
entschuldigung ich habe sie unterbrochen
durch unsere zeitliche Verzögerung das
tut mir sehr leid wollen sie den Satz
noch zu Ende
führen wir brauchen einfach
konkrete Zusicherungen dass das nicht
noch mal passiert z.B eine Reihe von
Anreizen die man schaffen könnte um das
waff
standsabkommen weiter durchzuführen
vielleicht unter Bedingungen eine eine
Befreiung von Sanktionen oder dass es
negative Sanktion gibt wenn das
Waffenstillstandsabkommen verletzt wird
es gibt keine Situation wo man Putin
völlig die Möglichkeit nehmen kann nicht
das waffenstilstandsabkommen zu
verletzen er muss es auch Willen es muss
bestimmte Anreize und Bestrafungen geben
um ihn dazu zu
bringen aber sagen wir es gibt also
diesen Waffenstillstand es gibt
Verhandlung aber es bedeutet für die
Ukraine sie verliert dabei Teil ihres
Territoriums was für ein Signal sendet
das aus auch an andere Länder z.B an
China im Bezug auf Taiwan um jetzt ein
Beispiel zu nennen was sendet das aus
wenn die un-karter für territoriale
Integrität also zum Schutz der
Unverletzlichkeit des staatlichen
Hoheitsgebiets wenn die dann nichts
zählt
der chinavgleich funktioniert hier nicht
denn die Vereinigten Staaten Deutschland
und die meisten anderen Länder der Welt
sehen Taiwan ja formell
als souveränes chinesisches Territorium
an es gibt ein allgemeines Verständnis
dass Taiwan sich in diesem Zusammenhang
selber
regiert
rechtlich
gesehen wird die Ukraine und die
westlichen Partner die werden keine
russische Okkupation
ukrainischen Hoheitsgebietes als legitim
ansehen wir
können
Russland beschuldigen dass sie
ukrainisches
hitsgebiet besetzt
hält die Republik
Südkorea geht auch davon aus dass die
Souveränität über ganz Korea hat wir
haben nie die russische Annektion von
der Krim 2014 anerkannt das sind große
Verletzungen der
un-karter und dafür muss jemand die
Verantwortung übernehmen aber ich sehe
keine Kaskade von
ähnlichen Verletzungen die daraus
entstehen weil die westlichen der
Ukraine ja
zusammenarbeiten um signifikante Kosten
Russland aufzubürden wegen der
Aggression Russlands das Wichtige dabei
ist dass es einfach unattraktiv sein
muss für Russland so zu handeln und ich
kann mir keinen chinesischen Führer oder
zukünftigen russischen Führer vorstellen
der nach dem 22 nach dem Februar 22 sagt
das war eine tolle Idee das machen wir
noch mal
es gibt Fragen noch an Sie hier bei uns
im Stream von Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauern und zwar gibt es hier eine
Frage ganz konkret von einem User der
fragt sie direkt was würden Sie machen
wenn Sie an der Stelle von Herrn
selenski wären also in seinen Schuhen
wären t das ist eine schwierige
Frage ich denke
mal ich könnte mir vorstellen dass ich
versuchen
würde die öffentlichen Erwartungen zu
managen ich glaube diese Erwartungen
sind erhöht worden über die letzten
Monate und ich glaube
eine Milderung dieser Erwartungen eine
Reduzierung der Erwartungen sass die
Erwartungen üereinstimmen mit dem W der
letzten ne Monate das würde zu
Möglichkeiten führen wo man in Zukunft
sich mehr Flexibilität schafft das
könnte eine potenzielle Handlungsweise
sein die ich vorschlagen könnte aber wie
gesagt das ist natürlich eine schwierige
Position in der selenski ist aus
verschiedensten
Gründen und es ist natürlich schwierig
sich in seine Position zu versetzen und
für ihn zu sprechen und zuletzt noch
eine weitere Frage an Sie aus dem Stream
wie verhandeln wenn die Gegenseite also
Russland nicht verhandeln will bzw die
Vorstellung einer Kapitulation gleich
kommen Russland wird die Kapitulation
der Ukraine sicherlich nicht bekommen
wenn sie unrealistische Forderungen
stellen dann haben wir immer noch die
Möglichkeit zu sagen okay wir hören mit
den Verhandlungen auf und die Ukraine
haben auch diese Chance
Verhandlungen zählen ja nicht darauf ab
dass man seine eigene Kapitulation
anbietet man versucht das gleiche zu
erreichen was man auf dem Schlachtfeld
versucht zu erreichen aber in einem
anderen Bereich das ist einfach eine
andere Art und Weise seine nationalen
Interessen zu erreichen das gilt für die
Ukraine für den Westen und eben auch für
R Land ich denke wir können erwarten
dass da hart verhandelt wird aber die
Kapitulation der Ukraine ist nicht auf
dem Tisch und sollte das auch nicht sein
und wenn Russland nicht ernsthaft
verhandeln will dann verlieren wir
nichts dadurch dass wir Vorschläge mal
ausprobieren die Einschätzung das
Politikberater Samuel ch vielen Dank
dass Sie heute mit ihrer Sicht bei uns
in der Sendung waren danke
Ihnen ich danke ihnen vielen
Dank Russland darf nicht gewinnen die
Ukraine darf nicht verlieren so die
Haltung des deutschen bundeskanzland
Kanzlers aber was heißt das genau wenn
die Waffen und die Munition aus dem
Westen nicht reichen um zu gewinnen wir
wollen jetzt hier in der Sendung auch
noch mal ein bisschen weiter über die
politische Seite von deutscher Seite und
den USA eingehen und was das alles
bedeutet das für euch einordnen was also
tun auch wenn die Hilfe eben aus den USA
und aus der von der EU stockt der
amerikanische Verteidigungsminister
Asten machte noch einmal deutlich wie
essenziell eine weitere Unterstützung
der Ukraine sei und auch wenn es nach
Bundeskanzler Scholz geht sollen die
EU-Staaten beim eu- Sondergipfel Anfang
Februar ihre Militärhilfe für die
Ukraine deutlich aufstocken und 50
Milliarden Euro Finanzhilfe für die
Ukraine vereinbaren dazu geht
Deutschland jetzt in Vorleistung um eben
den Druck auch auf die anderen
EU-Partner zu erhöhen wir hören mal rein
in zwei Töne dieser beiden
können wir unsere Unterstützung was
Waffen betrifft für die Ukraine
intensivieren Deutschland hat wie ich
eben schon berichtet habe ja ein Betrag
von deutlich über 7 Milliarden Euro in
seinem Haushalt jetzt
vorgesehen das ist sehr viel Geld aber
es wäre weit mehr als die Hälfte dessen
was alle anderen bisher geplant haben
das ist für uns ein Hinweis darauf dass
wir wünschen dass mehr Beiträge kommen
und diese Diskussion hat nun angefangen
und wird dort stattfinden aber
sicherlich auch noch danach
weitergehen der Kampf der Ukraine ist
für alle unsere Länder wichtig Putin
opfert in seinem überstürzten und
rücksichtslosen Krieg weiterhin eine
atemberaubende Zahl russischer Truppen
und Putin hofft dass Raketen und Drohnen
das ukrainische Volk demoralisieren und
den Kampfgeist des ukrainischen Militärs
brechen werden deshalb fordere ich diese
Länder auf tief in die Tasche zu greifen
um die Ukraine mit mehr lebensrettenden
bodengestützten Luftverteidigungssystem
und Abfangjägern auszustatten die
Ukraine hat auf Putins Grausamkeit mit
Mut und trotz
reagiert wir wollen die politische
Haltung der beiden ukraineeverbündeten
USA und Deutschland jetzt noch einmal
einordnen mit unseren Korrespondenten in
Washington und Berlin bei mir ist jetzt
Elm tesson in Washington und Andreas
küast in Berlin schön dass ihr beide da
seid hallo
hi
hallo fangen wir an wir haben eben
gerade den us Verteidigungsminister
Austin gehört wie sieht es aktuell aus
mit der usunterstützung für die
Ukraine ja da wird ganz heftig
verhandelt hinter den Kulissen gibt es
tatsächlich zwischen Abgeordneten im
Parlament all voran den Senatoren und
dem Weißen Haus auch Verhandlungen
darüber ob es noch mal ein neues großes
Paket für die Ukraine gibt
möglicherweise bis zu einem Volumen von
60 Milliarden Dollar für dieses Jahr
2024 aber dazu sind die republikanischen
Senatoren abgord nur bereit wenn es
massive Zugeständnisse bei der
Einwanderungspolitik gibt mit anderen
Worten wenn die Zuwanderung zu den USA
deutlich eingeschränkt wird da würde das
Weiße Haus möglicherweise zu
Kompromissen bereit sein
das würde im Umkehrschluss heißen wenn
man sich einigt dann könnte es große
Unterstützung für Ukraine geben denn
auch vielen Republikanern liegt daran
Putin nicht nachzugeben und die Ukraine
weiter zu unterstützen weil man eben
glaubt man darf am Ende Vladimir Putin
nicht den Sieg gönnen dass er im Grunde
beweisen kann dass die Karta der
Vereinten Nationen die territoriale
Integrität eines Landes nichts mehr wert
ist Andreas reden wir über deutsche
Lieferung deutsche Hilfen wir haben es
gerade eben gehört in einem Ton des
Bundeskanzlers also er ist stark für
weitere Hilfen von der EU aber reden wir
auch mal über Stichwort Taurus da gab es
heute Meldung das ist ja also ein
marsflugkörper den die Ukraine gerne
hätte immer wieder fordert es gibt
darüber Diskussionen schon seit Wochen
hier bei uns im Land und jetzt nach dpa
Informationen gibt es Überlegungen
natopartnern wie Großbritannien und
Frankreich Taurus Raketen der Bundeswehr
zu liefern also da wird so ein Tausch
erwogen im Gegenzug würden diese Länder
dann ähnliche nicht ganz so
leistungsstarke Waffensysteme in die
Ukraine exportieren das ist jetzt ein
Bericht was ist da dran ja das wäre
schon eine Möglichkeit um diese
quälerische Diskussion um diese
taurusmchflkörper zu beenden und da ist
was dran also es wird auf jeden Fall
überlegt in der Bundesregierung ob es
die Bundesregierung am Ende macht ist
noch die Frage es geht ja bei diesen
Taurus Marschflugkörpern um Waffen die
mit großer Präzision Ziele in bis zu 500
km Entfernung erreichen können und das
war immer der Grund aus dem
Bundeskanzler Scholz gezögert hat die zu
liefern weil er eben die Befürchtung
hatte dass die Ukraine damit ähm Objekte
angreift auf russischem Gebiet oder auf
Russisch besetztem Gebiet und die
Antwort seit Mai die wir immer wieder
gehört haben wenn wir gefragt haben war
es gibt keinen neuen stand jetzt gibt es
offenbar einen neuen stand also es gibt
die Idee die aus Großbritannien kommt
dass Deutschland seine
taurusmchflugkörper nach Großbritannien
liefert und auch nach Frankreich und
diese Länder dann ihre Storm Shadow oder
sculp in die Ukraine liefern das ist
offiziell nicht bestätigt der
Verteidigungsminister sagt er wisse von
nichts aber diese Überlegungen gibt es
die Deutsche Presseagentur die dpa hat
sie öffentlich gemacht und auch wir
haben gehört dass es zumindest diese
Überlegungen gibt und das ist schon sage
ich mal ein starkes Zeichen dass diese
quälende Diskussion zum Ende kommt jetzt
und ihr habt eben beide meinem Gespräch
mit Politikberater Samuel cherup
zugehört der da also seine Idee des
verhandlungsfriedens dargestellt hat die
Frage an euch beide zunächst an Dich
Elma ist das etwas tatsächlich worüber
gesprochen wird was du auch weißt in
politkreisen in den USA weil öffentlich
gibt es dazu ja eigentlich nichts zu
vermelden also man macht sich natürlich
Gedanken ob man und wenn ja wie man
irgendwie wieder aus diesem Krieg
rauskommt aber eigentlich die meisten
und das sind natürlich viele Demokraten
aber auch die Mehrheit unter den
Republikanern sind der festen
Überzeugung dass wenn man abrückt von
diesen Grundprinzipien territoriale
Integrität und Souveränität dass dann
Putin am Ende siegf sich reklamieren
könnte und dass er auch in der Lage wäre
danach anderweitig z.B im Baltikum oder
äh anderswo entsprechend Truppen zu
schicken deswegen ist das das
Minimalziel oder die minimalfung am Ende
müssen die russischen Truppen abziehen
und die Souveränität der Ukraine
komplett wiederhergestellt werden ob man
dann darüber reden kann dass diese
Gebiete ich sag mal eine Art neutralen
Status unterm Strich dann haben obwohl
sie zur Ukraine gehören und der Rest der
Ukraine dann beispielsweise eindeutig in
das westliche Bündnis in die NATO
integriert wird oder in die EU ob man
sich so etwas vorstellen kann sowas wird
natürlich diskutiert aber man
registriert auf russischer Seite an
keiner Stelle irgendeine Bewegung also
wenn Sergei lavrowov gestern hier bei
den Vereinten Nationen wieder einmal
heftig hinlangt und so tut als habe es
diesen Überfall aus Russland als diesen
Angriff nicht gegeben völkerrechtswidrig
als habe es das Massaker von butscha
nicht gegeben hat gestern gesagt dass er
alles inszeniert gewesen sagt
gleichzeitig aber Russland habe kein
Interesse anderswo anzugreifen dann hat
er hier wenig Glaubwürdigkeit und es
gibt nirgendwo das Signal für die
US-Regierung oder auch für die
Parlamentarier hier dass Russland auch
nur ein Yota bereit wäre abzurücken von
dem was an Maximalforderungen von Putin
formuliert wurde deswegen kann man sich
zwar hier Gedanken machen was man
vielleicht am Ende Russland anbieten
könnte wenn es bereit wäre ein Stück
weit abzurücken
aber das tut man natürlich nicht
offensiv in Gesprächen mit Russland und
schon gar nicht ohne die ukrainische
Regierung einzubinden und Andreas hier
bei uns in Deutschland wir haben ja eben
also am Anfang der Sendung darüber
gesprochen laut einem Spiegelbericht
soll zumindest der Kanzleramtsminister
ja bei einem Hintergrundgespräch in
Washington dabei gewesen sein wo also
auch über mögliche Verhandlung mit
Russland gesprochen wurde wird denn
darüber gesprochen wenn auch nicht
öffentlich in Berlin also offiziell die
Linie kennen wir alle offiziell ist die
Linie die territoriale Integrität der
Ukraine muss wiederhergestellt werden
und ich würde auch sagen inoffiziell ist
das wirklich die Meinung der
allermeisten politischen
Entscheidungsträger in Berlin das
wünschen sie sich das ist ähm das Ziel
das erreicht werden soll aber was auch
wahr ist ist dass die Bundesregierung
mit dem mit der Art der Debatte wie sie
in Deutschland läuft nicht so richtig
zufrieden ist sie kann das nicht so
direkt sagen deswegen sagen es andere
für sie wir kennen diese Äußerungen von
SPD Fraktionschef Mützen nicht von dem
SPD Außenpolitiker reif Stegner der
immer sagt nicht so sehr immer nur auf
das militärische sondern auch mal über
das diplomatische reden das ähm kann die
Bundesregierung nicht sagen weil ähm die
Ukraine natürlich äh solche Gedanken ähm
überhaupt nicht weil es dort solche
Gedanken überhaupt noch nicht gibt auch
in der Gesellschaft nicht auch in der
breiten ähm nicht nur in der Regierung
nicht sondern eben auch unter den
Menschen die eben sagen wir können nicht
mit den Leuten verhandeln die unsere
Kinder umbringen deswegen ist es
wirklich sehr schwer so ein eine
Position
einzunehmen der Gedanke dass die Ukraine
einen Waffenstillstand
abschließt und dabei auch
Gebietsverluste nicht akzeptiert aber
zumindest vorläufig hinnimmt das ist ein
Gedanke den es gibt in Berlin und auch
einer mit dem man glaube ich in Berlin
leben könnte und ich würde sogar noch
einen Schritt weitergehen sagen einer
der auch in die Gespräche mit der
Ukraine eingespeist wird das ist aber
alles illusorisch das ist aber alles
völlig nur Theorie solange es eins nicht
gibt nämlich Sicherheitsgarantien für
die Ukraine dass ich die Ukraine sicher
sein kann wenn wir einen
Waffenstillstand schließen und
Gebietsverluste nicht akzeptieren
sondern nur vorläufig hinnehmen bis es
zu einem richtigen Friedensschluss kommt
wir brauchen Sicherheitsgarantien und da
fand ich gestern bemerkenswert beim
Besuch des slowakischen
Ministerpräsidenten fizzo in Berlin dass
Bundeskanzler Scholz zum ersten Mal
mitgeteilt hat dass die Verhandlungen
über sich Sicherheitsgarantien dass ein
ab ein Sicherheitsabkommen mit der
Ukraine wie er sagt kurz vor dem
Abschluss stehe also wir hören ja in
Berlin das mit kurz vor dem Abschluss
gemeint ist februar und dass auch
Frankreich und das Vereinigte Königreich
über solche Sicherheitsabkommen
verhandeln das wissen wir auch das wäre
dann schon mal eine leicht andere
Ausgangslage um auch über Verhandlungen
mit Russland irgendwann eines Tages mal
zu
reden es gibt Fragen an euch beide aus
dem Stre die ich jetzt auch gerne mit
aufnehmen möchte eine die geht
vermutlich in deine Richtung Elm da
schreibt jemand kann man wirklich auf
produktiven Kompromiss hoffen in einem
Wahljahr dass die Welt selten gesehen
hat ich nehme an da geht's um die
US-Wahl es wird gewählt bei euch im
November 5050 die chossen dass am Ende
des Tages ein Präsident Trump auch
wieder im Weißen Haus sitzen könnte und
dessen Haltung im Bezug auf die Ukraine
und auch die Unterstützung wird
vermutlich dann eine ganz andere
sein ja und das ist auch der Grund warum
hier so ein bisschen das Gefühl von
eilees geboten entsteht weil die die
tatsächlich der festen Überzeugung sind
und das sind nicht nur Demokraten sonder
es sind auch eine ganze Reihe
republikanischer Senatoren Abgeordnete
sogar lindse Graham gehört zu denen die
der Meinung sind man muss der Ukraine
jetzt weiterhelfen weil in diesem Jahr
zählt es vielleicht ganz besonders in
Russland steht ja jetzt die Wahl an in
Russland werden die Verhältnisse
deutlich schwieriger die Preise sind in
die Höhe geschnellt
die Soldaten gehen gewissermaßen aus für
diesen Krieg für Wladimir Putin er gerät
zunehmend Druck so ist die Lesart hier
jetzt muss man es machen aber auch
deshalb weil natürlich ein Präsident
Trump ins Haus stehen könnte wenn er
denn die Präsidentschaftswahl im
November gewinnen sollte und wir wissen
von Donald Trump selbst aber vor allen
Dingen auch von seinen Helfern und
Unterstützern wir haben gestern mit
Steve bennon ausführlich darüber geredet
dass da so eine Lesart existiert in dem
Moment wo Trump ins Amt käme würde er
einen Deal machen wollen mit Wladimir
Putin der da heißt man würde Teile der
Ukraine auch aufgeben egal ob Kiev
zustimmt oder nicht also einen Deal
machen unter Verletzung der Karter der
Vereinten Nationen was territoriale
Integrität angeht warum weil man erstens
der Überzeugung ist Russland ist
mittlerweile so geschwächt dass es
militärisch eigentlich keine ernsthafte
Gefahr für den Rest Europas schon gar
nicht für echtes natoterritorium
darstellt das glauben einige unter
anderem Steve bnon und zum zweiten eben
weil man der festen über Zeugung ist
dass man Russland vielleicht sogar
absehbar als Verbündeten gewinnen könnte
in der Auseinandersetzung mit China die
als viel gefährlicher viel wichtiger
angesehen wird das ist das
trumpistenlager das ist deren Haltung
und je stärker Trump in den Vorwahlen
wird desto stärker hat das natürlich
Einfluss hier auch in Washington
deswegen der Deal von dem ich vorhin
sprach möglicherweise Zugeständnisse bei
der Zuwanderungspolitik dafür aber
Milliardenhilfen noch für die Ukraine
der könnte Mö möglicherweise auch in den
nächsten Tagen noch platzen eben weil
der Druck von Donald Trump und seinen
Anhängern hier im Parlament so groß ist
also möglicherweise wirklich Bewegung
drin sowohl in den USA als auch in
Deutschland im Februar oder in den
nächsten Tagen eine Frage Andreas an
dich aus dem Stream ist schs Strategie
Russland darf nicht gewinnen die Ukraine
nicht verlieren denn eine gute
Verhandlungsbasis na ja das
darf jeder für sich einschätzen es ist
auf jeden Fall die deutsche
Verhandlungsbasis und es ist eben in in
Nuancen eine andere als die
amerikanische es gibt ja auch in
Deutschland ein Politiker der sagt die
Ukraine muss gewinnen das ist der
Verteidigungsminister Boris Pistorius
aber Scholz und auch sein
außenpolitischer Berater Jens Plötner
vor allen Dingen versuchen ja doch auf
diplomatischem Wege Fortschritte zu
machen ich will mal erinnern an die
Verhandlungen die es jetzt gab in Davos
das war die vierte Verhandlungsrunde
eines
einer einer eines Zusammentreffens von
Diplomaten aus 80 Ländern da gab es
davor schon drei andere Treffen in
anderen Städten in jidda in
Saudi-Arabien in valalletta in Malta in
Kopenhagen und da hat sich Deutschland
so ein bisschen auch an die Spitze der
Bewegung gesetzt und nachdem man am
Anfang diese Verhandlungen ja so
mitgemacht hat hat dieser Jens blötner
der außenpolitische Berater von
Bundeskanzler Scholz jetzt so einen
gemeinsamen Namensartikel geschrieben
mit dem ukrainischen mit seinem
ukrainischen pondon mit der rechten Hand
von volodomir selenski mit Andrej
jermack und hat so ein bisschen
skizziert wie aus deutscher Sicht ein
Frieden mit Russland eines Tages
aussehen könnte
z.B ganz klar gesagt dass ein
einfrierenes Konfliktes nicht in Frage
kommt das wäre ungerecht das wäre unfair
aber was das interessante an diesen
Verhandlungen ist ist dass dort
natürlich Russland nicht dabei ist aber
dass Russland freundliche Staaten dabei
sind in jida war z.B China dabei jetzt
ähm hat hatten wir die Verhandlungsrunde
in Davos da war Brasilien dabei und die
übernehmen die Position der Russen und
tragen Sie vor und damit kommt es eben
zum ersten Mal auf diplomatischer Ebene
zu einem Austausch von Argumenten
vielleicht auch von
Forderungen von der russischen Seite mit
der ukrainischen Seite also von
Forderungen die einen Frieden betreffen
weil Ihr Gesprächspartner aus Washington
hatte ja vorhin zurecht gesagt es gibt
natürlich Verhandlungen zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine über den
Gefangenenaustausch z.B aber wenn immer
gesagt wird es gibt keine Diplomatie das
ist nicht wahr diese Frieden diese
Verhandlungen äh auf dieser 80
staatenebene sind keine
Friedensverhandlungen aber sie sind auch
nicht
nichts sie sind auch nicht nichts sagt
Andreas küners live aus Berlin Emma
twiissen vielen Dank live aus Washington
schön dass ihr da
wart bitte schön und damit ist dann auch
die Sendung zu Ende und ich möchte mich
gerne bei Euch verabschieden vielen Dank
für vielen Fragen und Kommentare und
sehr gerne bis zum nächsten Mal macht's
gut
tschüss